[Musique]
seconde
les adolescents de bretteville-sur-odon
prête qu'en font partie des 200 milles
jeunes en france à se prendre pour des
lutins des détectives des dragons voir
des vampires
tous ces jeux de rôlistes canet se
réunissent chaque semaine au club du
temple du rêve associations qu'ils ont
créés dans un seul but
explorez un monde imaginaire depuis 1974
date de création du jeu de rôle les
amateurs de cette activité ludique ne
cesse d'augmenter
ils se réunissent autour d'une simple
table muni de papiers et de débit zara 6
8 ou 10 face et il joue cela pendant des
heures chaque joueur reçoit en début de
partie une fiche d'état civil présentant
les caractéristiques du personnage à
interpréter et son but dans la partie
interrogés à tour de rôle par le maître
de jeu qui connaît le scénario
les joueurs lui explique comment ils
réagissent à un événement selon les
décisions prises face à un
rebondissement l'histoire évolué et
l'imagination fait le reste
cette dernière doit être inspirée d'une
culture cinématographique ou littéraire
du futur et du passé fantastique ce que
les passionnés appel entre autres
l'héroïque fantaisie médiévale steel
wheels au cinéma et le space opera
attiré par exemple de la trilogie de
george lucas la guerre des étoiles
en fait je crois que le jeune drôle ça
vient surtout compléter un besoin si
besoin c'est de s'évader en fait est de
vivre autre chose que ce que l'on vit
tous les jours quand on fait un jeu de
rôle on s'évade vraiment et on a
vraiment l'impression de vivre des
choses qu'on peut pas vivre autrement
est ce que les participants se découvre
des qualités ou des défauts lors de lors
du jeu tout à fait que ce soit dans les
jeux grandeur nature ou dans les jeux
sur table on peut soit voir qu'on a
plutôt des affinités dans les
personnages qu'ils ne combattent pas
comme les magiciens ou
les marchands ou alors on peut se
découvrir plutôt des affinités guerrière
en jouant des guerriers que ces barbares
non en règle orages en règle générale on
peut dire que le jeu de rôle et une
découverte de soi même dans une certaine
façon je pense que oui plus qu'une
découverte de soi le jeu de rôle est un
excellent moyen de se retrouver en petit
comité
ils exigent une finesse de raisonnement
une ouverture d'esprit et un sens de la
communication
d'où la création de deux dérivés d'une
part les figurines qui est plus un jeu
de stratégie que de véritables
investigations les joueurs mettent
autant de temps à mettre en place les
petites figurines qu'à jouer d'autre
part le jeu de rôle grandeur nature
certaines personnes en fait ce sont dit
que au lieu de vivre des aventures
autour d'une table et vécue par mes
heures de jeu en fait on pouvait dans
une certaine manière le jouer réellement
c'est à dire que ces parcelles sont
costumés présente si on joue dans un
monde médiéval fantastique on se
costumant guerrier au magicien et on
recrée le monde dans lequel on évolue
d'habitude autour d'une table alors la
particularité de ce jeu grandeur nature
et bien en fait c'est un côté théâtral
plus qu'un simple jeu de cow boys
indiens ou le seul but est de se taper
dessus
pas vraiment chaque joueur ici aussi
incarne un personnage et joue vraiment
un rôle
notre équipement vient en fait de ce
conte de ce qu'on aime le plus c'est à
dire que bon ben c'est ce qui nous
corresponde le mieux
moi par exemple j'ai décidé d'être on
appelle un paladin parce que jamais ça
ce que je voulais donc en fonction de la
profession du personnage on fait
l'équipement serre que bon si on n'est
pas là d'un on a droit un bouclier des
armes longues des grosses épées etc des
armures et si on est plutôt d'un style
jeteurs de sorts
dans ce cas là on est plutôt en robe
avec des armes courtes petit est par
contre dont on a le droit à une
contrepartie en sort chose comme ça le
jeu de rôle grandeur nature en quelques
mots
mais c'est formidable
[Musique]